[Musique]
alors un conseil pour accélérer le
rythme de la cérémonie si vous montez
sur scène ce soir
ne me remerciez pas à vos parents dans
soyons honnêtes sur usenet s'il vous
avez véritablement élevé avec attention
si vous avez donné tout l'amour que vous
méritiez vraiment vous ne seriez pas
dans le cinéma voit pas l'anglais c'est
normal on te l'a pas me gêner ça pour
quoi parce que voilà on sait bien que
toute façon tu vas dire le nom que tu
veux donc c'était il ya longtemps c'est
j'ai mûri tu sais ok je cherche une
enveloppe mais je vais rester près de
toi attend 10 mois alors est qu'est-ce
qui se passe
et ben non tu vois tu n'en non libyens
tous les maux et dis moi que c'est
jacques audiard pour le profit premier
film c'est toujours non lâchez moi je
vous dis mais c'est ma passion je
voulais en parler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'étais chez moi devant la télé je me
suis dit c'est trop con vas zidani
excusez mon allure c'est pas que j'ai
pas eu le temps de m'habiller c'est pas
que j'ai pas le temps de m'habiller
c'est en fait c'est mon smoking des
césar
ces couacs en jeu quand j'ai acheté au
magasin ils m'ont dit monsieur bonne
franchement c'est pas la peine qu'on
vous vende le bas vous l'aurez jamais le
césar donc un vous le voulez comics vous
rester tout le temps à sion autant
rester assis à l'aise et voilà je
voudrais dire toute la vérité sur cette
polémique il ya une vérité voilà un
sérieusement pardon mais en fait c'est
mon conseiller en communication qui m'a
monté le bourrichon jacques séguéla qui
va d'ici à quarante ans t'as pas un
césar c'est que t'as raté ta vie
[Applaudissements]
un pognon que l'art est costaud avec la
bande de baltringues que jamais vous
voir gérard pourquoi tu me parles
toujours marrant comme ça non parce que
finalement c'est un peu comme si tu
disais exactement le contraire de ce que
tu penses j'ai peur de ce que tu ressens
pour moi voilà tu vois c'est safina
français que j'aime cinéma qui fait des
câlins
mais quand gun ma chère kate et tiki
tiki ti cats my sweet quête il n'est
jamais trop tard pour gagner à césar is
never to let twin césar car kate les
battous finish echos' kate winslet
parce que moi je colle xavier beauvois
des hommes et des dieux je n'ai rien
contre lui personnellement mais ça
ressemble plus à un documentaire
tibérine que
est ce qu'on peut
je ne se passe bien la cour
je reste pas pour gas bourrin ce pas
françois si on pouvait maintenant
remettre le césar je vais tuer pays
brabant pour les nommés dans cette
catégorie meilleur acteur dans un second
rôle
jamel debbouze dans le fabuleux destin
d'amélie poulain
[Applaudissements]
enfin
merci
merci infiniment sincèrement c'est un
outil qui ne peux pas vous dire césar
comme ça je m'y attendais pas du tout
jamel et puis dans sa tombe
c'est la consécration comme chanel c'est
bon je suis con c'est grave et jamel
jamel jamel s'est pas lassé
c'est super aussi mais c'est juste un
petit n'est pas encore finie d'ouvrir
une enveloppe est ce que tu te ment
exactement jusqu'où
non non j'attendais juste je voudrais
remercier tout le monde
c'est le plus beau jour de ma vie mais
non c'est avec le jour où j'étais à
auchan avec mon père nous pepita capital
le capital mais c'est bien aussi mais
c'est les réparations mais c'est bien ça
fait plaisir tu peux me donner mon truc
simple un petit nom de césar est
attribuée à andré dussollier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
par exemple l'année dernière meilleure
actrice vous souvenez qui étaient nommés
n'ont par contre vous souvenez très bien
qu'il a eue
bérénice bejo pardon bérénice béjo non
c'est moi qui ai non c'est bérénice bejo
dans the artist mais non c'est dujardin
dans the artist
mais sont tombés un bébé nous phoque
nous recueillons fouquet
un rôle que nous d'enghien bon pour soi
florence jeudi pour soi non pas bonsoir
je te plaît ah pardon c'est pas la fin
je veux dire c'est pas écrit dans le
scénario du pire tu es gentil
ah bon florence naturel un scénario
c'est la clé de voûte de l'édifice
cinématographique
le public est conquis par sa verve
dustin hoffman lui semble subir bouchon
bonsoir ce petit bout de bonne femme
d'un rappel man un sondage sudaf leur
hausse découle que sean penn est assis
au premier rang
il était résistible mans attiré par la
jeune comédienne
n'y tenant plus il se précipite sur
celles dont la rejoindre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dia qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est vrai je
suis pas prêt de faire l'amour tout le
temps comme ça que je pense
pour la première année consécutive
l'académie des césar va donner un césar
aux acteurs de second plan
dans la catégorie césar du meilleur
acteur de second plan
les nommés sont valérie douville pour
stand by
[Applaudissements]
hervé gecko mots pour harry un ami qui
vous veut tourner
[Applaudissements]
christophe legendre pour le goût des
autres
et fabrice firmin pour saint cyr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le césar est attribué à christophe
legendre pour le goût des autres
évidemment j'ai juste envie de remercier
le casting figuration directeur laurent
soul et qui a eu l'audace de de me
confier ce rôle alors que comme vous
avez pu de le voir dans cet extrait
physiquement on ne correspondait pas du
tout merci à bernard le coq dans se
souvenir des belles choses
bernard n'est pas là il joue au théâtre
vous avez bien fait vraiment vous avez
bien fait
je veux pas [ __ ] la merde je suis venu
en toute amitié
je vais pas rester très longtemps je
vais pas partir comme l'année dernière
avec le sens excuse moi ça voulait tout
le respect que j'ai pour comédiens ici
je fais faire un oscar chez smalto sur
mesure jeter sur le chemin de la voix je
vois pas ce qu'elle prépare à un gros
plan sur les robert soit du robert
farouchement à une sauvegarde
je suis mari michel bordas je suis
présidente du fan-club des tutsis de
france au nom de toutes les femmes dans
les canons de beauté ne correspond pas à
la norme
merci merci d'avoir donné la parole aux
femmes d'agir ne recourant pas en
paillettes de la chirurgie esthétique
comme c'est trop souvent le cas dans
notre profession
mesdames soyez vous même
ici vous n'y arrivez pas il ya peut-être
une autre solution
être un homme
le scénario c'est la colonne vertébrale
d'un film et la moelle épinière que sont
les que les actes et les acteurs keith
et les acteurs qui en fait qui sent la
moelle épinière que sansan la colonne
vertébrale sept mois c'est la moelle
épinière que sont les acteurs ne
trouvent ils ne trouveraient ne saurait
pas où ce coût se situe pour se situer
pour remettre le césar
m et me meyer comme sorry i'm sorry
there sigourney weaver j'allais absolut
et nos problèmes de batterie je
comprends le français ça va
tant pis alors écoute aise rien
sigourney weaver
alors écoutez moi tu es très simplement
moi j'avais des noms je pense quelqu'un
a gagné vous savez comment ça fonctionne
ça fait 25 ans il serait temps donc il
ya des noms tout le monde a un peu gagné
mais l'un plus gagné que les autres il
reste un petit poucet rien et même un
petit peu c'est well more or less mort
laisse carrière américaine dans les deux
ans pour moi donc lui le cinéma français
et les baisers qu'un film de merde
merci bonsoir il est drôle il est tendre
il est émouvant c'est une boule
d'énergie et de bonne humeur
kad merad
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu pilotes juste je sais juste comme je
croyais en prob avec eric cantona ici
sans bruit et patrice carmouze dans les
dents les noms pourquoi va le faire tout
seul c'est pas bien ça pour quoi
tu vas me dire vous serez pas s'ennuyer
petite scène non faut pas vous avez pas
le parti de sel quand même je vais pas
te manger la culotte de cheval
vous savez comment te dire je suis un
peu vos yeux sont aussi rapides que
disait dans la collision d'un oiseau
et vos cheveux la coupe de cheveux longs
cheveux sont aussi espiègle qui avait
les cheveux d'un oiseau oui jamel jamel
vous plaît jamais là c'est possible je
pense jamais à loisy elle ne parle pas
très bien français j'ai bien compris que
membre à la bbc ça c'est encore le
voisin il se met tout le temps là tommy
lui persuadé que c'est son parc et non
pas girard patrick juvet tu veux un café
j'ai pas patrick jp garrett est garée
rue de gt gt gavage et au téléphone
garer avec virage
voilà soir avant de toute chose je suis
très honoré de remettre le césar du
meilleur court métrage
je voulais tout particulièrement
remercié l'académie des césars de
d'avoir pensé à moi pour remettre ce
prix car ayant participé à plus
[Applaudissements]
qui
thank you
[Musique]
donc oui président oui le président me
demande si vous pourriez faire un petit
peu plus bref s'il vous plaît c'est trop
long ah ouais
allawi
jamais lui c'est sa petite femme aussi à
mon avis hein
quand celle où et quand c'est trop long
quand c'est pas marrant on l'a vu ton
speech au début un
tu sais voilà dans mac os des mois ce
qu'elle a dit qu'elle avait raison
jamais c'est toujours la même chose je
vais partir mais juste off
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]